(ethereal instrumental music)
- We're about to head into the
Microsoft press conference.
There is going to be a
showcase event right after
where there will be food
and drinks and game capture.
That sounds like the
most perfect event to me.
I'm hoping there's
gonna be some surprises.
There's been some rumors going around
that they do have some surprises.
And you know what I like?
I like surprises.
So let's go get surprised.
Ed, what are you laughing about?
What are you laughing?
- Because you got real
creepy on surprises.
- Surprises.
- I like surprises.
Let's go get surprised.
I'm surprised.
Guys, this is my buddy, this is my friend.
I'm so excited to see you.
It is so good to see you.
- Oh, I'm so excited to see you.
What was our first time?
Was it, it was at the game awards.
- It was the game awards.
When we presented...
- Four years ago, for
John Bing, rest in peace.
I'm so glad we got to do that.
I'm so glad I got to do that with you.
His memory is kind of alive right here.
- It really was, that was
such a special moment too.
And just to be able to do that.
And that was the first time we met,
and we had such a fun time,
like, just chatting about games
and being friends and
now you've come so far.
- Yes!
- Guys, this is crazy. How much
weight have you lost so far?
- I've lost exactly two of you.
- Oh my goodness.
But that's amazing,
and I'm just so happy to
see you doing so well.
- Thank you.
- And you made it to E3.
- And I'm able to walk
around, and I'm able to move,
and I'm able to do stuff.
- It's so exciting.
- Can I get a hug?
- Yes of course. You're the best.
Anything that you're
really looking forward to
this year at E3?
What's your highlight?
- I'm hoping to get to
play the Anthem demo.
I'm super excited to try it.
I'm really excited to see
what Microsoft has in store.
I'm hoping they've got a few surprises.
- I think they do, that's what I've heard.
I like surprises.
- And if I can, I just need five minutes
alone with Smash 'cause I have to see
if it's as good as I hope it's gonna be.
And I know it's almost
impossible to get in line.
Even to see it.
I know you'll get to play it, probably.
I just need to know if Pacman
got brought over to this one.
If Pacman's in this one, it's
gonna be the best Smash ever.
- I hope so, but I can't wait.
Well, I'm excited for
you, I'm excited for E3.
- I'm so excited.
- So here we go. E3, 2018 starts now.
We're heading over to Microsoft.
- Let's go have fun.
- Okay, yay!
(bouncy upbeat music)
This is it, let's get a seat.
So when we walked in the
first thing that I noticed
is all of these consoles on the stage.
Do you think this is some
sort of Battle Royale?
- [Ed] Oooh.
- [Justine] Have you guys
heard about Battle Royale?
- Maybe there's going to be 100 people
on stage playing one game.
What's that even like?
- [Justine] I don't know.
(epic music)
- We are all shook to the core.
(Presenter talking)
(epic music)
(audience cheering)
- He's actually crying.
- I'm already crying.
(audience cheering)
- Now, we are bringing
the Fallout universe
to X class gamepass with
Fallout 4 launching today.
(Presenter talking)
(audience cheering)
- Walls are just buildings.
but hearts, minds, and,
ultimately, America itself.
(epic music)
(audience cheering)
- Forza Farmville means
Forza Battle Royale.
Ralph, let's talk about it.
- [Narrator] Dynamic seasons
- Farm!
- Farm.
- In a shared open world. And
seasons change everything.
(Game trailer playing)
- [Woman] So you guys are coming or what?
Yeah.
- We just got out of the press conference,
and I'm with Ed and Faruk,
and what do we think?
Who wants to go first?
Ed cried.
I couldn't see if you
were crying, I saw Ed cry.
- I want to apologize for screaming
when they announced Cyberpunk 2077.
(typing)
- Yeah.
- Yes!
Yes!
Oh my God.
- I've never seen Ed this happy ever.
- I've been waiting for that
game for like eight years,
and I don't think anybody
really knew about it.
I thought it was like
another Watch Dogs thing,
because the way everything
was getting hacked and stuff.
And they said the year was 2077,
and they hadn't said the game yet,
and I stood up and screamed,
and I scared everybody.
- You scared me.
- Yes.
- Fallout, you hyped for that?
- I couldn't be more hyped for Fallout.
They showed more, but then
tonight we see even more
so I'm excited to see
some gameplay hopefully.
- Well, it was kinda
crazy 'cause they really
just went all in, like at the beginning.
They were like "Hey,
what's up? Halo Infinite."
I've been to a bunch of
press conferences before
but I've never seen a standing ovation
at the very beginning.
That was wild.
That was Halo Infinite, and there's this.
Everybody is standing up and cheering.
Do you have any highlights?
- Dying light 2 was amazing.
Little known information: in Dying light 1
there's this one scene, and
the person in that scene
has the same first name
and last name as me.
- What?
- So people send that
clip to me all the time.
- No way!
- I also liked Forza,
that looked really good.
I love car racing simulations.
Grip and the way the car handles
changes with the seasons.
- The conditions on the roads
are different every time.
Like wet leaves and stuff like that.
That looked pretty awesome.
- I was just thinking back to Destiny,
every time we would see an
event incoming or something,
we would be racing, but then sometimes
I'd be going to the wrong event,
and Ed would be at another event,
and Jenna's eating pizza or eating chips,
and I'm like "What are you eating?"
- Or in a cave, just hiding for a while.
- Yeah.
Man, we had so much fun playing Destiny.
Every time we eat Doritos,
I just think about Destiny.
(laughter)
- I think about how your
controller's still clean,
but your thumbs were so orange.
So hats off to Microsoft
on the white thumb sticks.
- 2018 E3 is here.
It has just begun.
I don't know what's happening
next but stay tuned.
I mobile ordered this
from the press conference.
Oh, there's some friends.
Hello!
- Those reactions.
- We've met up with some wild friends.
Were you guys at the E3?
- We were at the E3, yes.
- We were at D3, which is
a whole different thing.
- Do you guys have any highlights?
- Anime fighting game.
- All about it.
- Battletoes.
- Were you the one that yelled?
Okay, I heard that.
- It was me or him.
- I heard screaming.
- Battleboys.
- It was so funny to hear the most random,
just little pits of the audience screaming
for certain things.
Like Ed stood up
and was crying about
Cyberpunk, like screaming.
- Of course.
- [Justine] Screaming!
- Eight years I've been waiting for that.
- Oh my God, it's perfect.
- It was great.
Yeah, wow.
Wow, so we're here.
Can you believe E3's here again?
- I know.
Almost feels like VidCon right now
looking down at the line.
- [Justine] Oh my gosh.
- [Man] Everybody from YouTube in one.
- [Justine] This is
like the YouTube squad.
We're super excited, we're about
to get our game capture on.
This is the Microsoft showcase event,
it's after the press conference,
and Nick is walking backwards right now.
He's gonna fall, he's
definitely gonna fall.
(epic dubstep music)
Somebody's gonna do some shopping.
Spoiler alert: me.
Okay, but do you guys remember
when I got the chocolate lancer?
Do you guys remember that?
(unwrapping)
How many calories do you think?
Let's not think.
(powerful electronic music)
So we just figured out
what all of those Xboxes
were on the stage for, it was
for this particular moment
that we're about to enjoy right now.
Game capture.
Got my little hard drive.
This is how we capture.
We've got Forza,
we've got copywritten
music playing as always.
Why do you guys do this?
The Adaptive Controller.
So this is something
I'm really, really excited about.
This was actually
announced a few weeks ago.
It's the Xbox Adaptive Controller,
and this is really incredible,
and I'm so excited to learn more about it.
And it was amazing to
see all of the tweets
and the amazing response of the community
to this controller.
This is gonna help so many people,
and I'm so excited to see how
this will change the game for so many.
Alright, I didn't wanna pick
that car but I picked it.
Shoot.
Can I cancel?
Can I go back?
Nope, this is what we got.
We've got a McLaren Senna.
I'm okay with that.
(game noises)
What,
did I just do?
Oh my...
We're...
I did so bad that they had
to remove me from the game.
There's a sheep.
There's a sheep!
We are now in winter.
Let's get it.
(fast electronic music)
This music has me so hyped.
Get out of my way.
Okay, ice is crazy to actually drive on.
What is happening?
Move.
Out of the way.
Oh my gosh.
Look at this festival.
I'm definitely yelling.
Am I yelling?
'Cause it's very, my
headphones are so loud.
We're in spring now.
(car engine roaring)
Noooooo.
Woohooo.
Woooow... Wow.
You just got jacked up.
Are we going into summer now?
Let's get it.
- [Narrator] This is it, Horizon.
We are kicking off the summer season
with the greatest race of all time.
Oh yeah.
- Where did you guys come from?
Watch this.
See that?
That was impeccable passing.
What?
They're Ori cookies.
They're not gonna mind.
- [Cameraman] No, they're not.
We've got a lot of cookies coming.
- Really?
- We have a lot of cookies coming.
- [Man] They don't mind.
- So behind the scenes now
of the YouTube Live show.
They've been doing this for
the past couple of years,
and it's really fun.
They do tons of E3 re-caps,
and we're about to be on the show.
Let's go.
(bouncy techno music)
- Like to see from Nintendo here, at E3.
- I want Streetpass,
so bad.
One of the reasons that you
know, I still was bringing
my Nintendo 3DS around to events
because Streetpass is one of
my most favorite things ever.
And I think that was one of the joys of E3
and going to big events was
collecting Streetpasses.
- (inaudible) with Reggie and his team,
and he was playing Animal crossing
on his phone.
- I thought you said he was gonna play
Animal crossing on a
Switch, I was about ready
to flip this table.
Reggie, where are you?
- Yeah, he was playing
Animal crossing on mobile.
We'll see, I guess, but that's
(inaudible) Animal Crossing Switch.
- You would probably see me cry.
I think you would also
see my friend Ed cry.
Who actually almost, well,
he cried several times during
the Microsoft press conference.
When they were talking about Fallout.
Actual tears.
And then at the end Cyperpunk.
Well, I'm gonna go eat these cookies now
and I'll see you guys for more E3 fun.
This is just day one,
and this isn't even technically day one.
This is still just the press day.
There's still so much more E3 to come.
So that being said, I'm
gonna go eat these cookies.
Like I just said.
(bouncy electronic music)